[Musique]
peut se penser la télévision et un est
un moyen d'expression qui peut se passer
du découpage et du gros plan quoi qu'on
en dise et du plan d'ensemble je vois
que la télévision est une chose qu'on
doit avoir comme un journal et qu'on
doit mettre en cage comme un journal
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas de la
recherche et la division de profondeur
dans le champ qu'un écran est trop petit
pour qu'on puisse vraiment l'apprécier
propice à subir
je crois qu'une image et illusions doit
se dire du premier coup et non plus être
dû au montage rapide ça existe pas je
vois que le spectateur doit analyser
parce qu'il le peut parce qu'il est tout
près du poste parce qu'il est attentif
parce que il domine le poste lors quel
écran le domine de grands des grandes
filles majeures le domine le spectateur
lui domine son poste et donc il peut
analyser l'image très finement à
condition qu'ils regardent la télévision
non pas en mangeant mais on regarde les
vidéos qu'on vous la regardez c'est à
dire en savons rien d'autre de toute
manière c'était un biographe planches
grincer des dents ou bien la course du
texte à cause de la subversion même du
texte même et en plus à cause du
découpage car jamais je ne me suis
forcée du moins de détruire une notion
de raccords dans le temps dans l'espace
il voulait les gens apparaissent quand
j'aurai besoin quand ils en ont le plus
besoin et disparaissent et puis somme
toute c'est un hommage que j'ai rendu à
jarry karila il pas écrit ubu roi pour
comme ça il a préféré face c'est ce qui
s'appelle la fenêtre fameuse de
l'inutilité du théâtre au théâtre
et ouais je crois que j'ai fait deux
lignes du diacre à la télévision pour
faire de la télévision je vois il faut
oublier toutes les formes d'expression
avec qui l'ont précédé
car je crois profondément à la vertu
spécifique de des visions comme langage
d'expression n'ont pas qu'aux véhicules
programme
oui écoutez là je vais demander beaucoup
d'indulgence aux spectateurs non pas
qu'ils me disent assiette de faire des
critiques je réclame et même si les
critiques sont violentes et acerbe et
même injuste ça sera de l'enseignement
de profonds droit car je pense que les
gens qui croient que au moins leur
métier ou du moins qui en font l'horizon
profonde de vivre ont besoin de se faire
engueuler pour réagir
mais je lui demande au spectateur que je
ne connais pas mais que je sais être à
monsieur intelligent je lui demande ce
soir là non pas de regarder la
télévision comme on ouvre son frigidaire
programme fier du jambon ou du poulet
pour manger je trouve quelque chose de
bon mais de faire un effort
supplémentaire
on risque de le trouver vide ce poste
même s'il est déçu sur le résultat final
du spectacle lui demande de faire un
effort d'aidé mais au moins l'effort que
j'ai fait moi